je m'appelle closure donc je suis le
dirigeant de la secte société royaume
d'anatolie qui se situait au 25 août
satory je suis éloigné de benali le
pizzaïolo chefs de restaurants aux
bottega nous sommes situés dans le
quartier saint louis à versailles rue du
général leclerc
oh
lors du vernissage en allemagne d'accord
allez social en allemagne beaucoup de
restaurants tueur que préparent les
berliner de type 1 ou complets pain
complet et ça donne un goût extra sur le
sandwich et les crayons pas fan non on a
déjà deux premières manches en la maison
puis à lapierre directement préparer du
matin et le grand best seller le
berliner le pont on ajoute surtout les
légumes
donc ça la tomate oignons choux carottes
maïs il s'en plaint ont trouvé le son du
chien de de kebab on la compagne de la
feta c'est un concept qui commence à
venir tout petit à petit en france mais
ça commence à prendre sa place qui
commence à détrôner le point
traditionnelle salade tomate oignon nous
avons été élus donc au tout début
meilleur kebab d'ezzedine après après ce
meilleur cab a désigné une grâce aux
prions que je les remercie infiniment
nous sommes devenus à leur jour à
l'heure actuelle mais au kebab de france
[Musique]
dans l'eau restaurant que ce soit celui
de versailles ou à liancourt on propose
une carte variée des produits italiens
des plats italiens des pizzas italiennes
donc avec des produits frais les
produits italiens pour faire une bonne
pizza c'est pas très compliqué donc il
faut de la bonne farine c'est une farine
à vichy en gluten
cette farine on peut la mélanger avec de
l'eau la levure sel huile d'olive pour
avoir le meilleur résultat il faut
sortir notre pâte à pizza deux heures
avant le service pour avoir une pâte
bien reposé et assez élastique pour la
travailler pour gagner une bonne pizza
on a besoin de la tomate bio et alien sa
matteo donc ya pas d'acidité on utilise
également des produits frais pour gagner
une bonne pizza donc on utilise la vraie
mozzarella de bufflonne donc ça a
vraiment le goût du lait c'est pas un
produit industriel ensuite on utilise de
la tomate fraîche du basilic frais avant
d'enfourner on doit mettre un peu
d'huile d'olive
extra-vierge origines italiennes et de
l'origan et là on va enfourner donc
notre pizza
[Musique]
donc voilà la cuisson est parfaite
alors comment on peut reconnaître une
pizza de qualité c'est une pizza qui
peut tenir comme ça sans assiette on a
été sélectionné par une association
italienne pour la qualité de notre pizza
et nos produits en 2018 et 2019 on a été
classé troisième en ile de france
[Musique]
pourquoi kebab c'est simple la pizza en
fin de match parce que les trous à
préparer les kebabs il faut moins de 30
secondes vous avez votre kebab devant le
match vous pouvez assister
tranquillement les 90 minutes pf s'est
fait refaire la pizza et stoïquement
quand on dit un match de foot on dit
partage on dit pizza on a plus
facilement la peau cité par se partager
une pizza qu'un kebab le produit il est
facile à vivre et transporté réchauffer
à la maison des produits à ce qui me
concerne il ya beaucoup plus de choix un
kebab à l'élève c'est vers ça et moi je
suis très content pour versailles bon
courage et bonne chance
on compte sur vous c'est une première
donc faut aller jusqu'au bout